الدبلوماسيه الكوارث لم تصطدم بخرسانات
متهاويه لكنها تخطتها لترفع جدران عزله
احاطت بالنظام السوري لسنوات واعادت خلط
اوراق الرئيس التركي السياسيه
زلزال السادس من فبراير حله مدمرا قتل
وفرق وشرد لكنه اسقط حواجز وخلافات سياسيه
هيمنه على علاقات دول لحين لملمه الماساه
فازاح الدول لا ترتبط بعلاقات طيبه مع
تركيا او سوريا ملفاتها موضع الخلاف
وانضمت الى قافله المساعدين واشنطن
استعانت باستثناءات خاصه بالعمليات
الانسانيه لتعلق العقوبات المفروضه على
سوريا وتسمح بادخال المساعده اليها
وفي وقت ارسلت فرق انقاذ لتركيا اكتفت
بتقديم المساعده لسوريا عبر شركاء محليين
لرفضها التعامل مع الاسد اما في تركيا
فانفتح الطاقات التعاون من مختلف الجهات
فالحدود مع ارمينيا فتحت لاول مره منذ
عقود لادخال المساعدات رغم خلافات تاريخيه
الجار اليوناني تخطط توترات كادت ان تصل
لمواجهه عسكريه بسبب نزاعات على جزر
وتنقيب عن مصادر الطاقه دبلوماسيه الزلزال
شملت زياره لوزير الخارجيه اليوناني برفقه
نظيره التركيه الى انطاكيا وارسال مساعدات
انسانيه وفرق اغاثه وعمال انقاذ لتحقق ما
قاله السفير التركي السابق لدى اثنا
بخطابه الوداعي تمنيات بعدم الحاجه لكوارث
او زلازل لتذكر الجيره
السويد تناست موقفه تركيا المعرقله لمسع
انضمامها لحلف شمال الاطلسي فطور
والعلاقات لم يؤخر مصر كذلك عن ارسال
مساعدات طبيه الى تركيا كما لم تؤثر
العمليات العسكريه التركيه شمال العراق في
تضمين انقره بالجسر الجوي الاغاثي